Carter's parents Sarah and Chris Cookson
who saw in that report are joining us
now live from New Castle Chris Sarah
thank you very much indeed for talking
to us an incredibly difficult time for
you as a family you're in a race against
time now for little Carter what if the
doctors said I've just had a bit of an
update this morning and throughout the
day just it's it's sort of every hour is
is crucial and constantly looking up
that machine to make sure that it's it's
still you know it's still able to keep
Carter alive and the clots on too much
of an issue but they are actually
forming thought it could be it could be
hours it could be you could get another
24 hours with them it's just really you
don't know it's kind of in the hands of
medical science with the machine that's
Izzy's life support at the moment here
Chris that machine is keeping Carter
alive at the moment but it has its
complications they were just talking to
us about the clots how is he he doing
causes him mean he selfie selfies that
you ease doing the rights that the
complications with the machine is yet
your organs can start a fail and lucky
for Carter his organs are not fear them
and everything aside it's working it's
it's worth and well but the hard part
for us is it's what's coming that it's
it's a machine that's back that's cotton
and if the Machine clot that stops at
birth blow from going through the
machine into August body because the
machine is is basically keeping his
heart and lungs in life and if that
machine clots the COG got the correct
flow and go to the body which means
there's an oxygenated blood doesn't get
the organs I need it and the hard part
for says the conversation will just hide
with them within the last 24 hours as
they said if the machine cuts again the
unchanging again and it's been changed
three times in the part in the past but
these kind eyes are coming out his neck
which where the Bloods comin out and out
of that become so fragile that the still
users have said the corn change it again
and after us and he means one thing is
if that machine closed in the next hour
2 hours 24 hours only option we have is
to turn that machine off and if we turn
that machine off it's telling his life
off because it's keeping his heart and
lungs going without the machine he can't
survive but there's nothing else the
surgeons and the consultants can do the
only thing we can pray for now is in the
next hour two hours three hours or a day
a hard dawn that comes forward if that
hard talk daughter does not come forward
for us we don't get to take us at home
and what he had to go through the
heartache of bearing our thirst and
Charlie when he was two and a half and
it's gonna kill what to do it again and
no parent should ever have to go through
that it is unimaginably tragic the
situation that you find yourselves in
Krishna Sarah and and Sarah having lost
your first son Charlie and and to have
gone through all of that the decision to
have another baby in itself was a
difficult one for you to make and now
you find yourself faced with this yeah I
mean it took a good five years forward
to build the courage up to actually try
for another baby and rubble found I was
at the boy obviously were all the joy
thinking you know this could be the
second second chance of having a family
but a lot of people just can't get their
heads around that this is this is
actually happening and including
ourselves until it's you know the
reality kinda hits when the face when we
look at them and we'll have the
conversations with the doctors it's it's
absolutely devastating it will you know
it's killing us every day you see even
right this is just no night he's not
giving up the fight his body is still
want to be here it's just that one organ
that could be provided by you know the
devastation and heartache of another
family and you know all I could say is
if we are in that situation we don't get
the hard for our little boy you know we
don't think twice about donating his
organs to try and save the life of
another child because we for the first
time in our lives we've been on the
receiving end of this and it's
no parent should go through it no and we
heard you in that report a little bit
earlier describing that feeling of
helplessness Chris that there's nothing
you can don't go out and do you can't go
out and buy a heart you can't fix him
you're entirely dependent on the
kindness of strangers
that's there than any any parent over
there any and you any mom and dad
watching this they'll know that they
would do anything they could to to help
that help their child out whether it was
a sickness or in the flu or him a sore
leg him and I'm sure right now every
parent out there would back me up by
saying that if I could give my heart
then I would but my heart's too big for
Carter you know I can't give anything
and like I said this this there's
nothing I can do to help him and we can
redo his cares and and in read a book in
there as a witch in the day and their
main time and I can only hope it but we
can't do anything else right now we're
not that's the really hard part it's
it's in the hands of somebody coming
forward with a donation and as a parent
if he was so helpless and kills me that
I can't help my son and in serozha
saying that there's nothing we can do as
parents to make any difference that
what's happening now we can only be by
your side and do his ears and do what we
can do as parents right now and that's
that's it
but I'm only hoping we get take him home
and and do what normal parents do and
that's all we want that's all with
Charlie we didn't get it and it's all
were praying for now with Connor Sarah
wait when did you first know that there
was something wrong with Carter um I
would see this design started to appear
maybe saw four or five hours in terms of
arrivin it got very very tight ed and he
was struggling to to take any milk from
the bottle and he was very just a weak
looking and it wasn't until the nurse
came in and she tried to feed him and
agreed that you know he was going to
have to be too afraid which that law and
was scary for me and Chris because we
thought you know this the
the one thing to another because it was
a bit of a DejaVu city we should not
hide with Charlie but from to Galway and
then for a doctor tell me that it's not
just a case of an NG tube it's a case of
he's actually been ventilated because
he's heartless soul or was just horrific
I think it didn't it was happening very
very quickly and it didn't didn't sink
in so you go sorry to interrupt me Sarah
so you go from the elation of his birth
and yet your beautiful baby boy to this
absolute fear of what's going to happen
next and the last three weeks within
hours of his birth caster has suffered
three cardiac arrests and he's been
fighting ever since
yeah Izzy's he's got a lot of strength
in him I think that's the difficult
thing it's you know he's a feisty little
character and he's just you know he does
Teddy he doesn't want to have his leg
there and even though he can't sort of
communicate very well with you you do
see his personality in there and it's a
very strong one and I think it's its
willingness to keep going until it's
absolutely final that that machine has
got to be taken away there's nothing
else that can do with it
and because he's like that we will
continue to be as strong for him until
we can't physically do anything else I
mean I think you're incredibly
courageous doing what you're doing as
you say what else can you do in this
situation you've also Kris had a lot of
support we saw the candlelit vigil in
South Shields last night and what does
that meant to you
it supports being phenomenal with him
for some shields our our tone live being
there being fantastic and but it hasn't
just been South Shields it's been all
over the UK and that you the stretches
all over the world that I'm honest with
you we've had messages from Germany from
Greece from Australia from Spain from
Thailand and there's so many more places
that we've had messages from complete
strangers who have seen our our story
and have seen what we're going through
in this
sending messages and the Korean for and
that's that is so good to feel that
we're known if not just his mom and dad
that doing that best friend we've got
everyone out there exactly who's praying
for him and and the praying somebody
kind of comes forward and Carla gets a
child to survive but it's we've got a
huge backing behind where we'll have
people bring us food in it be no food
downstairs to the to the reception desk
in the hospital you know and it's all
it's all call us a call to and presence
in but in itself is just it's it's
unbelievable and I don't think we began
through this if we never had the support
everyone on social media knows I it's
just fantastic
what can people watching this feeling
your pain watching you what can they do
to help I think it's it's just a case of
raising awareness it's you know what
we're doing this for fun sort of
personal basis for us but I think it's
really opened our eyes and a lot of
other people's eyes as to if you donate
your organs to me it's not just donate
an organ it's it's it's in a life for
somebody else and I think it's really
opened our eyes as to what we would do
with with ourselves and what we would do
with quarter and I think what people
would do with their own children if they
were in this this circumstances and you
know if they could do something to help
I think it's just really get the word
out there that is life-changing for
people in our situation and it can be
done
I've always say don't don't look at it
as organ donation look at it as saving
their life and that is what you doing
this you may be scared by the fact that
you someone said would you donate your
organs please do not look at it that way
and looking at us saving their life and
the fast that everything is changed so
the open donation law has changed but
everyone oxen and it's crucial because I
wouldn't want anybody to be sitting in
the same situation I'm sitting right now
and we're sitting right now in the fear
of losing our son within minutes or
hours or days and I don't want anybody
in
that situation and if we can change the
novel so you can save their life
so many lives can be saved in the
teacher and I only hope that we when I
was fight the otter and and if we don't
we'll try and save someone else's bands
like the dog inside he has and it can't
ever do that as well we'll try and get
slow changed as soon as possible because
that's what has to be done